the message of mandated vaccines is
about the protection of vulnerable
people
but where does it leave workers who
don't want it
andy is one of them he's a carer and
we're protecting his identity
he's not full-time staff but he's worked
for the same company for five years
when they learned he didn't want the jab
they cancelled his shifts
and asked him to leave by the end of the
week about a week or two barely yet or
anything so i was just stressed i
thought i was losing my job before
i was going to pay my bills and feed my
children
days later they u-turned he's back to
work but still feels vulnerable
and how did that whole experience make
you feel worthless
just like all the workers for nothing
and it was just like basically if you
don't
do what we want you won't have a job
do you accept though that getting the
vaccine is more about protecting the
people that you're looking after and
what are your reasons for not wanting it
the benefits of the vaccine don't
outweigh the risks for me for me
any age it should always be a choice
anyway my nose doesn't like these
regulators say the benefits do outweigh
the risks
and getting one matters for places like
this
but the latest data shows only 79 of
care home staff in england have been
vaccinated
the government's now consulting on
whether to mandate it
there's absolutely don't no doubt in my
mind that
that we would like a 100 vaccination so
we absolutely understand the rationale
behind this
i think the timing is a bit challenging
because we've only just had the vaccine
access availability since about the end
of january so we're not we're not
talking about long period of time
the debate over mandatory vaccines is
unlikely to stop in the care and medical
setting
but it poses huge ethical questions for
employers
which strikes to the heart of how much
right they have to intervene
in a worker's personal life many say
they need more guidance
but as life reopens debate redoubles
covert status certificates for instance
questioned by the equality and human
rights commission
experts say no jab no job may not even
be legal
it is no doubt an impingement those
rights are engaged
but all these rights have clawback
provisions they have
exceptions and the government can
act in the interests of public health
experts say the vaccine is safe but
should not wanting it cost you your job
helena smith sky news